I'll tell you what struck me when we
started looking at this subject is that
as we've come out with the pandemic the
numbers are huge you know 1.7 million
persistent absence
125 000 severely absent and the 95 000
children missing from education and
often we don't know where they are yeah
now I just wonder whether we should
start this by accepting that you and the
government have not got a good enough
grip
on this crisis well I wouldn't accept
that I haven't got a good enough grip
but I would say I would suggest that it
I'd agree with you that it is a crisis
you know obviously we got in place uh
these attendance um sort of leads in
each of our local authorities they're
working with all of the schools some of
the schools are doing a fantastic job we
have a moment now and I'm really
delighted to be able to talk about this
right now because what we know
statistically is if children start
school in September they are more likely
to stay in school
let's take the attendance attendance
subs and mentors it's going to get in
touch with about 1600 pupils that's one
percent of all the severely absent
pupils it's just not enough is it well
we've just expanded it actually to
another um four or five places as well
the number I've just quoted includes
that expansion of places The Stoke
knowsley yeah knows these where I'm from
that pilot which which the government
talks a lot about is only going to
impact at best one percent of all the
severely absent children it's just not
ambitious enough is it well you have to
you have to learn from these to think
what's working but it's not the only
thing that we're doing so we already
have schools working with other schools
you know we have best practice that
we're sharing as well we have a guidance
that we've put out which has a lot of
that best practice in as well the reason
why I asked you whether you whether the
government thinks it has a good enough
grip on this huge problem you know it's
huge I know it's huge is that I've lost
count of how many head teachers I've
spoken to in the last four months who
are driving to their pupils houses to
pick them up in the morning to get them
into school because that's the only way
that they can get into school now if
you're all these schemes that you're
mentioning are working why have we got
head teachers picking up well to be
honest people's in school but they do
have the duty they have the duty they do
have the duty authorities you're right
with that teachers doing that we all
have to play our part and actually I
have a number of head teachers who work
with me on policy and they say sometimes
you just have to do that sometimes you
have to go or you have to text the
parent in the morning and say you know
sometimes you just have to have those
but do you think whatever is possible
yeah but do you think that's a good use
of a head teacher's time in 2023 I think
it's good used to have all kids in
school and sometimes you know do you
think a head teachers should be doing it
well that's not what we want head
teachers to be doing all the days but to
be honest right now if they were if that
works to get somebody in school it's
worth it if you feel left behind it
makes you very anxious if you feel
really left behind it makes you even
more anxious and you talk about left
behind it I think a lot of these
children do feel like that I was quite
surprised when we looked at the
statistics for children missing
education last year at any point there
were 95 000 children missing education
now there's a voluntary register yeah to
keep an eye on them when are you going
to put forward primary legislation
that makes it mandatory for us to put a
register together so we know where all
these kids are because at the moment
they're absolutely invisible yeah I
completely agree and it's something that
many of my fellow MPS
are very concerned about as well and I
get asked it on a regular basis I don't
have the exact date answer because it's
a parliamentary process that we have to
go through but we do intend to put it on
a statutory footing and we will do that
as soon as as the Parliamentary time
allows I've committed uh to to do this I
just can't say exactly when